l'esprit la fête de la musique c'est la
rencontre l'amour les changes le partage
le bonheur d'être ensemble chanté et
dansé dans les rues comme dans la
plupart des villes s'étaient bien
souvent la fête de la musique spontanée
[Musique]
tout début j'étais assez inquiet je vais
vous lire
ça a été le plus grand traque de ma vie
vous imaginez on prend la responsabilité
de dire aux gens le 21 juin
chacun où tous prend son instrument de
musique où sa voix vous n'avez que sa
voix et dans les plats sur lui pour les
jardins etc
et après tout ce raffut n'a pas marché
du tout
[Musique]
toute façon je pense pas que les gens
n'aient que les gens qui descendent
jamais dans la rue vivement ce soir les
musiciens qui jouent dans la rue si les
autres restent chez eux tout début
c'était plus le temps n'était pas
nécessairement le plus excitant il n'y
avait plus
non c'était ce n'est pas déshonorant on
s'en est pas trop mal sorti mais ce
n'était pas encore le bon et laisser les
premiers audacieux les premiers
courageux génie des pros des za de
rendez vous manqués la fête de la
musique n'éclabousse pas encore la ville
de fraîcheur et d'imprévus reste une
mélodie balade pleine de charme et aussi
d'espoir beaucoup de journalistes être
lavé qu'est ce que j'ai fait cette idée
dingue
à preuve le bizarroïde un journal très
chic à gauche avait titré je crois vive
le concert de casseroles
[Musique]
ça tient un peu du miracle encore une
fois quand je les imaginais je ne
pensais pas que l'événement d'abord
durerait jeanne imaginez pas qu'il
deviendrait mon diable et surtout qui
s'inscrirait sept plus importants dans
la mémoire dans les têtes dans les
coeurs constituant une sorte de rituel
annuel à nulle autre pareille
[Musique]